Depression is often misunderstood in the
public.
Sometimes people think that people with
depression are weak or lazy when in
actuality,
um,
people with depression are struggling
with a very complex illness that has
biological,
psychological,
and social causes and consequences.
Depression is extremely common.
It affects one in four women and about
one in five or six men,
and those who don't experience
depression themselves often have a
friend or family member who are
experiencing it.
The most commonly experienced symptoms
of depression are sad.
Mood and lack of pleasure,
people often no sleep changes in energy
changes.
And almost everybody I've ever
interviewed,
which would be over 2000 people with
depression,
I'll experienced feelings of
worthlessness.
Almost every single one.
Depression is an invisible illness.
It's not one that you can see just by
looking at somebody's normal.
Sadness can occur in response to life
events.
Depression,
at least in its later stages,
tends to be disconnected from actual
life events.
So depression and sadness share the
sadness,
but depression is so much more than just
sadness.
And as a matter of fact,
some people think the worst part of
depression is now experiencing pleasure.
There's a numbness and how sometimes
when people have severe depression field
pull yourself up by the bootstraps,
you should get yourself out of this or
things like your life is great.
What do you have to be depressed about?
Depression is definitely not related to
someone's character or moral
shortcomings and it's really interesting
the thing that if medication can help
people who have these illnesses,
how could it really be about their
morality?
Depression can affect every aspect of a
person's life.
It can affect their job performance,
their family relationships,
their divorce rates are higher.
I can affect their parenting abilities
and depression is one of the leading
causes of economic burden of any
diseases.
People are often surprised to hear that
it costs more to the society then cancer
or heart disease.
If depression goes untreated,
it could turn out a variety of different
ways.
It could be that people stay at the same
sort of,
um,
negative level that they've been.
Or sometimes it can get much worse so it
can,
with each passing depression,
some people feel worse and worse so that
they might have approximately about 20
percent of people I believe with major
depression ended up making some form of
suicide attempt.
So the question is,
how do we get people to feel better so
that they can think better or vice
versa,
how do we get them to think differently
so that they can feel differently?
Usually people come at depression with
one form of treatment or the other.
They'll either go and get medication or
the goal get psychotherapy where they'll
do nothing.
In fact,
the data support that the best treatment
for depression is a combination of
medication and psychotherapy.
I think there's a lots of strategies
that people can use in order to try to
feel better,
um,
improving their sleep and sleep hygiene,
exercising 30 minutes a day.
Um,
it's particularly aerobic exercise seems
to be very effective for people at
depression.
And for the social piece,
I'd really recommend to try to develop
more social engagement with people
because again,
I think that's one way that people can
actually help themselves.
To feel better.
The good news is that depression is a
very treatable illness.
The majority of people who get care,
particularly if they can get care early,
we'll end up doing very well.